he's an author speaker and consultant
who writes on leadership and management
he joined the RAND Corporation in 2010
where he advises on military innovation
in planning he's known for popularizing
the concepts of the golden circle and to
start with why he's simon Sinek and
here's my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number six is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
although to the end for some special
bonus clips and as always if Simon says
something that really really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
let me tell you a story so a friend of
mine and I we went for a run in Central
Park the Roadrunners organization on the
weekends they host races and it's very
common at the end of the race they'll
have a sponsor who will give away
something apples or bagels or something
and on this particular day when we got
to the end of the run there were some
free bagels and they had picnic tables
set up and on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels and on the other side was a long
line of runners waiting to get their
free bagel so I said to my friend let's
let's get a bagel and he looked at me
and said that lines too long and I said
free bagel and he said I don't want to
wait in line and I was like free bagel
and he says not that's it's too long and
that's when I realized that there's two
ways to see the world some people see
the thing that they want and some people
see the thing that prevents them from
getting the thing that they want I could
only see the bagels he could only see
the line and so I walked up to the line
I leaned in between two people put my
hand in the box
and pulled out two bagels and no one get
mad at me because the rule is you can go
after whatever you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it you can do it your way you can
break the rules you just can't get in
the way of somebody else getting what
they want that's rule number one
performing under pressure whether it's
me or anybody else is the same you know
I have the same pressures as anyone else
there's time there's performance
is financial I mean there oh you know
there's deadlines my pressures are not
unique the situation may be different or
you know but but everybody has the same
kinds of pressures but what I found or
what I find fascinating is the
interpretation of the stimuli let me let
me explain so I was watching the
Olympics this last number level and I
was amazed at how bad the questions were
that the reporters would ask all the
athletes and almost always they asked
the same question whether they were
about to compete or after they competed
were you nervous right and to a tee all
the athletes went no right and what I
realized is it's not that they're not
nervous if their interpretation of
what's happening in their bodies I mean
what it what happens when you're nervous
right your heart rate starts to go your
you know you sort of get a little tense
you get a little sweaty right
you have expectation of what's coming
and we interpreted that is I'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing at the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
Olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say as nervous as excited they
also the same thing no I'm not nervous
I'm excited and so I've actually
practiced it just to tell myself when I
start to get nervous that this is
excitement you know and so where when
you used to be speaking from a large
audience somebody'd say how do you feel
it's a little nervous now when somebody
says how do you feel like really excited
actually and it it came from just sort
of telling myself no no this is
excitement and it becomes a little bit
automatic later on but it's kind of a
remarkable thing to deal with pressure
by interpreting what your body is
experiencing as excitement rather than
nerves and it's really kind of effective
it makes you want to rush for is rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience I talked to so many smart
fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard-working kids and they're right out
of college they're in their entry-level
jobs and I'll ask
how is it going and they'll say I think
I'm gonna quit and I'm like fine they
say to me I'm not making an impact I'm
like you know you've been here eight
months right
[Music]
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired I mean it was mutual or they're
quitting because they're not making an
impact or they're not finding the thing
they're looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love a job you find joy from is not
something you discover it's not like I
found love here it is I found a job I
love that's not how it works both of
those things require hard work you are
in love because you work very hard every
single day of your life to stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the mountain this large a
movable object that doesn't mean you
have to do your time that's not what I'm
talking about
take a helicopter climb I don't care but
there's still a mountain life career
fulfillment relationships our journeys
the problem is this entire generation
has an institutionalized sense of
impatience and do they have the patience
to go on the journey to maintain love to
feel fulfill or do they just quit and on
to the next dumpin on to the neck ghost
and unto the next in the 18th century
there was something that spread across
Europe and eventually made its way to
America where Apple fever also known as
the Black Death of child bed basically
what was happening is women were giving
birth
and they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth was the
ravage of Europe and it got worse and
worse and worse over the course of over
a century in some hospitals it was as
high as 70% of women who gave birth who
would die as a result of giving birth
but this was the Renaissance this was
the time of empirical data and science
and we had thrown away things like
tradition and mysticism these were men
of science these were doctors and these
doctors and men of science wanted to
study and try and find the reason for
this black death of childbed and so they
got to work studying and they would
study the corpses of the of the women
who had died and in the morning they
would conduct autopsies and then in the
afternoon they would go and deliver
babies and finish their rounds and it
wasn't until somewhere in the mid 1800s
that dr. Oliver Wendell Holmes father of
Supreme Court justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes realized that all of these
doctors who conducting autopsies in the
morning weren't washing their hands
before they delivered babies in the
afternoon and he pointed it out and said
guys you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy for 30 years until finally
somebody realized that if they simply
washed their hands it would go away and
that's exactly what happened when they
started sterilizing their instruments
and washing their hands the black death
of childbed disappeared my point is the
lesson here is sometimes you're the
problem we've seen this happen all too
recently with our new men of science and
empirical studies these Menace finance
who are smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapse and they blamed
everything else except themselves and my
point is is take accountability for your
actions you can take all the credit in
the world for the things that you do
right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must be a balanced equation you
don't get it one way and not the other
you get to take credit when you also
take accountability
I spoke at an education summit for
Microsoft I also spoke at an education
summit for education from Mike at the
education summit for Microsoft I would
say that 70% of the executives spent
about 70% of their presentations talking
about how to beat Apple at the Apple
education summit a hundred percent of
the executives spent a hundred percent
of their presentations talking about how
to help teachers teach and how to help
students learn one is playing this way
and one is playing that one is playing
finite and the other one is playing
infinite gets which one gets frustrated
so at the end of my talk at Microsoft
that gave me a gift they gave me the new
Zune when it was a thing and let me tell
you this thing was spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology I've ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular I absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and it didn't work on iTunes
which is a different problem I couldn't
use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant
so I'm sitting in the back of the taxi
with a very senior Apple executive sort
of employee number 12 kind of guy and
you know I like to stir pots so I turned
him I said you know Microsoft gave me
their new zoom and it is so much better
than your iPod touch and he turned to me
and he said I have no doubt
conversation over
[Applause]
[Music]
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's work the goal isn't to be
the best every day the goal isn't out to
outdo your competition every day
that's a finite construction if I had
said to Microsoft I've got the new ipod
touch and it's so much better than your
Zune
they would have said can we see it what
does it do react react react react
finite player is play to be bet to beat
the people around them infinite players
play to be better than themselves to
wake up every single day and say how can
we make our company a better version of
itself today than it was yesterday how
can we create a product this week that's
better than the product you created last
year we also have to play the instant
game it's not about being ranked number
one it's not about having more followers
on Twitter than your friends it's not
about outdoing anyone it's about how to
outdo yourself it's not about selling
more books or getting more 10 views than
somebody else it's about how to make
sure that the work that you're producing
is better than you working produced
before you are your competition and that
is what ensures you stay in the game the
longest and that is what ensures you
find joy because the joy comes not from
comparison but from advancement when are
you at your best
I met my best when I'm around people who
believe what I believe I know it seems
silly but I try very very hard to sort
of stack the deck you know to put myself
in a position of strength so for example
you know somebody asked me just
yesterday have you ever had sort of a
bad you know engagement I was thinking
myself I'm like not really but it's not
because I'm some sort of sort of genius
understanding anything like that it's
because I stack the deck it's because I
want to be there I want to be around
people who want me there in other words
if I'm somebody's tenth choice you're
like you know I'll probably turn it down
whereas if I'm their first choice they
really won't be there
I'm more likely to have a good
engagement they're supportive of me I'm
supportive of them and so yeah I'm at my
best when I stack the deck when I choose
to be in an environment where my
strengths are right there Nelson Mandela
is a particularly special case study in
the leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader he was actually the son of
a tribal chief and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with other elders one they
would always sit in a circle and to his
father was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen I would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what I
think but I'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things
one it gives everybody else the feeling
that they have been heard the give way
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed and two you
get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion the skill is really
to keep your opinions to yourself if you
agree with somebody don't nod yes if you
disagree with somebody don't not know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying and at the end
you will get your turn it sounds easy
it's not practice being the last to
speak that's what Nelson Mandela did
decision-making is a process right the
question is what filters are you using
to make decisions are you making
decisions based on the financial rewards
are you making decisions based on how
easy the work will be I mean I remember
in college you know they would give you
this book where they all the students
would rate the classes and they would
rate things like how easy the class was
and how you know how much do you they
like the professor and you know the
first year I picked all my classes based
on it workload and I picked everything a
low workload you know and pretty bored
didn't work very hard which was fine
but nothing was dynamic and nothing
really excited me and I thank goodness
learned that and so the second year I
picked all my classes by professor
rating regardless of the workload so
every class I had I had these dynamic
amazing incredible human beings
passing on their knowledge and you were
excited to work hard for them you know
and so again what the question is what
are the filters we were using and so if
you're only chasing the mighty dollar
then you will have jobs that'll pay you
a little more than the last but you
enjoying yourself and I talked to a guy
recently who wasn't he's in bad shape
like he really hates his life and he's
really depressed he doesn't know what to
do and so we were going through all his
old jobs you know and I said give me a
job that you've loved and he hadn't
every single job he's chosen out of
college he picked because of the the
money and if something offered him or
somewhere else he took it you know
regardless and and and the amazing thing
is he plateaued because if you're only
chasing the result if you're only
chasing the thing that makes it easy
right then eventually you will get bored
or they'll get bored of you right and
you Plateau
in other words chasing the old mighty
dollar if that's your only thing it
eventually flattens out whereas if
you're chasing the thing that excites
you the human beings to be around the
work that excites you the stuff that you
know you know you you can get passionate
about you know the the irony is is
you'll actually make way way more right
because you're excited and they
appreciate your excitement and they
reward your excitement and you're better
at your work because you want to work
harder and all of that stuff you don't
have to strain to work harder so
decision making a Siddal is simply a
matter of filters you know and so I've
made decisions in my life that I would
rather be happy than right I
good then
then get rich and and so the decisions I
make put in positions where would I
leave any engagement when I leave any
meeting I feel that I've contributed
right where are the times anymore we
were crying
[Music]
you know
because that doesn't feel nuts and the
experience I have
I don't enjoy traveling to them and I
don't enjoy our traveling home we're
gonna have an amazing experience I am
looking forward to getting there and I'm
excited when I leave you know so it's
just decision decision making is just a
matter of what filters you use and if
you're if you're good about keeping
those filters up and clear then then
make the decision I don't judge anybody
by how if they choose to use different
filters these are just the filters I
choose to live my life you know not
right or wrong just those are my
decisions
you know that's my filter how can you
help the human race how can you help the
human race human species progress
I'm not joking either this is something
I think we all have to be aware of at
the end of the day the human animals are
social animal and our very survival
depends on our ability to form
communities to form cultures what's a
community what's a culture it's a group
of people with a common set of values
and beliefs right
what's a country it's a group of people
with a common set of values and beliefs
what's a company it should be a group of
people with a common set of values and
beliefs when we're surrounded by people
who believe what we believe something
remarkable happens Trust emerges and
make no mistake of it trust as a feeling
a distinctly human feeling you know we
all have friends we're total screw-ups
and yet we still trust them right Trust
is not a checklist if we doing
everything you say you're going to do
doesn't that much does not mean people
will inherently trust you it just means
you're reliable
we need trust right we need trust when
we're surrounded by people who believe
what we believe and trust starts to
emerge and we trust them and they trust
us we're more willing to take risks
we're more willing to experiment which
requires failure we're more willing to
explore and go somewhere with that no
one has ever gone before with the
confidence that if we fail if we trip
over if we turn our backs that those
within our community those who we trust
and who trust us will look after us
while we're gone we'll pick us up when
we fall over will help us when we're
hurt our very survival
depends on it we're not good at
everything we're not good by ourselves
you know if I send you out to go fight a
saber-toothed tiger by yourself odds are
Tiger one you zero it's not gonna go
very well but if you go out as a group
we're pretty damn amazing
and the reason is is because we all have
our strengths and we all of our certain
weaknesses and the goal is not to fix
your weaknesses the goal is to amplify
your strengths and surround yourself
with the people who can do what you
can't do but it's not just based on
skills and an application and experience
it's based on what you believe it's
based on what you believe you see simply
being good at something and having
somebody else being good what you're no
good at does not mean you will trust
each other trust the sense of trust
comes from the sense of common values
and common beliefs I can prove it how
many of you from New York okay
bunch of you are you friends with
everybody in New York why not why not
but when you go to Los Angeles and you
meet someone from New York you're like
hey how about New York and your best
friend's right and when you go to France
you there you are on the Paris Metro
minding your own business and you're
here in American accent behind you and
you turn around and say hey where're you
from
they say Los Angeles you're like hey I'm
from New York and you're best friends
because when you're surrounded by people
who don't believe what you believe when
you're in a strange environment where
you don't feel comfortable you look for
anyone who may share some of the same
values and beliefs that you have and you
start to form a very wheat real and very
intense bond with them simply because
you know that they have a basic
understanding of how you grew up of the
things that you care about or the life
that you live back home well the same is
true when we go to work do we want to go
to work with people who understand us
who believe what we believe who have a
similar view of the world that has
nothing to do with their opinions and
the differences that we share
that's good that's called diversity
that's called advantages to
problem-solving which is we can all look
at the same thing from a different angle
and come up with solutions what I'm
talking about is why should you help
each other in the first place what are
you in pursuit of
now the question is is what creates that
sense of values and believes what
creates that sense of trust our very
human instinct we know how to find
people who believe what we believe our
survival depends on it
we're biologically gifted with this idea
if I ask you to go out in the street and
find all the people who believe what you
believe you know exactly what to do
you're gonna strike up conversations
you're gonna start talking to people and
nearly either you'll have a good feeling
about them or you want either you'll
have chemistry whatever that means where
you don't sometimes it's quick sometimes
it's slow but we know how to do it it's
called making friends it's called dating
it's called networking we have the
innate ability to do it true story there
was a former Undersecretary of Defense
who was invited to give a speech at a
large conference about a thousand people
and he was standing on the stage with
his cup of coffee and a Styrofoam cup
giving his prepare to march with his
powerpoint behind him
and he took a sip of his coffee and he
smiled and he looked down at the coffee
and then he went off-script
and he said you know last year I spoke
at this exact same conference last year
I was still the undersecretary and when
I spoke here last year they flew me here
business class and when I arrived at the
airport there was somebody waiting for
me to take me to my hotel and they took
me to my hotel and they had already
checked me in and they just took me up
to my room and the next morning I came
downstairs and there was someone waiting
in the lobby to greet me and they drove
me to this here same venue they took me
through the back entrance and took me
into the green room and handed me a
coffee cup of coffee in a beautiful
ceramic cup
he says I'm no longer the undersecretary
a flew here coach I took a taxi to my
hotel and I checked myself in when I
came down the lobby this morning I took
another taxi to this venue I came in the
front door and found my way backstage
and when I asked someone do you have any
coffee he pointed to the coffee machine
in the corner and I poured myself a cup
of coffee into this here
Foam Cup he says the lesson is the
ceramic cup was never meant for me it
was meant for the position I held I
deserved a Styrofoam cup remember this
as you gain Fame as you gain fortune as
you gain position and seniority people
will treat you better they will hold
doors open for you they will get you a
cup of tea and coffee without you even
asking they will call you sir and ma'am
and they will give you stuff none of
that stuff is meant for you that stuff
is meant for the position you hold it is
meant for the level that you have
achieved of leader or success or
whatever you want to call it but you
will always deserve a Styrofoam cup
remember that remember that lesson of
humility and gratitude you can accept
all the free stuff you can accept all
the perks absolutely you can enjoy them
but just be grateful for them and know
that they're not for you I remember
getting off the Acela I took the Acela
from New York to Washington DC and I got
off the train like everybody else and I
was walking down the platform like
everyone else and I walked past general
Nordy Schwartz who used to be the chief
of staff of the United States Air Force
the head of the Air Force and here I did
see a guy in a suit slepping his own
suitcase down the platform just like me
and just a couple months ago he was
flying on private jets and a tan
entourage and other people carried his
light luggage but he no longer held the
position and so now he got to drag his
own suitcase and never did it sort of
remind me more that none of us deserve
the perks that we get we all deserve a
styrofoam cup every decision we make in
our lives as individuals or as
organizations is a piece of
communication it's our way of saying
something about who we are and what we
believe this is why authenticity matters
this is why you have to say
and do the things you actually believe
because the things you say and do are
symbols of who you are and we look for
those symbols so we can find people who
believe what we believe our very
survival depends on it so if you're
putting out false symbols you will
attract people to those symbols but you
won't be able to form trust with them
this is what Tiger Woods did to us he
lied he lied he told us what he thought
we wanted to hear and it was great and
we were drawn to it and all of us who
kind of liked that idea of that sort of
the good guy
we're drawn to it until we found out it
was a lie he could have been the bad boy
of gold he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great athletes of our day but he didn't
he chose to live good luck forming trust
again tiger we don't believe you we
don't trust you the goal of putting
something out there if you say what you
believe and you do what you believe you
will attract people who believe what you
believe if you go to one of your friends
and you say to one of your friends how
would you like me to dress so that
you'll like me better
how would do you want me to address you
how do you want me to speak so that
you'll like me more right your friends
are gonna look at you be like what are
you talking about yeah come on come on
come on what should I wear so that
you'll find me more appealing and how
would you like me to speak to you so
that you'll like me more and your
friends are gonna tell you just be
yourself that's why I like you I don't
just be yourself now think about what we
do in industry what do we do we do
market research we don't we ask the
customers what kind of things away with
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things you'll like us more
it's just as ridiculous it's just as
ridiculous organizations should say and
do the things they actually believe and
they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying cynicism sets in and
people start saying I'm not sure I can
trust these guys because there's not a
lot of consistency and all the things
they say and do
which means they can't have a very
strong belief set or they're lying to me
and we call them it authentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me all these positioning
studies we do are inherent
we're going to do a study to find out
from people so we can be more authentic
that's hilarious
say and do what you actually believe in
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats are ways that people can find you
what you have the ability to do as
designers is create those symbols and
allow people to use those things to say
something about who they are work for
companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself and your part is to
put what they believe into pictures and
words and symbols and graphics so that
other people can use those things to say
something about who they are people put
harley-davidson logos on their body to
say something about who they are
corporate logo ain't no Procter &
Gamble's tattooed on anybody's on
because Harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on they're not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves you ever see anybody with a
with a Mac laptop put a sticker over
that beautiful shining Apple ain't never
gonna happen then how will you know who
I am
give us to anybody with a PC break out
the Windex to clean out their computer
Mac people have you ever seen a dirty
Mac doesn't exist does not exist why
because it's Who I am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear and what they
believe and their discipline and how
they do it they're consistent what they
do and everything they say and
everything they do serves as a symbol of
the set of values and beliefs we use
those symbols to say something about who
we are we surround ourselves with the
people and the products and the brands
that say something about who we are
and when we confine the people who
believe what we believe were weirdly
drawn to them because our very survival
depends on it we need it and so the more
you can give of yourself the more you
can give of what you believe the more
you can discipline with discipline
saying boo and do the things you
actually believe strange things start to
happen what are your thoughts and what's
your approach on finding in building
upon passions passion is not an
actionable word it's correct you know
that those who do the things that
they're passionate about do better but
it's not helpful advice and so the
question is where does passion come from
passion is a result passion is an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that you
love passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know and I think
we mistake that passion is something we
do in our private lives but it shouldn't
be done you know in our careers for
example and I'm a firm believer that you
are who you are and anybody who says I'm
different at home than I am at work and
one of those two places you're lying
and the goal is to make everything you
do in home and it works something that
you have excitement to do so how do you
find the things that you're excited to
do well it's actually easier than you
think what are the things that you love
to do what are the things that you would
do for free you know how can you
recreate that feeling and and be paid
for it so what are the things that I do
in the weekend right I love I'm very
involved in the art world I love to go
to museums and galleries but I love to
go see dance and performances because I
want to see how others are interpreting
the world so that inspires me new ideas
new thoughts new ways of looking at the
world are are things that interest me
privately and I seek it out and pay
money for it
right so does that mean I have to have a
career in the arts no it means I have to
have a career where new ideas are
explored where people are experimenting
and trying things out and I have to
explore new ideas and try things out and
I'm just as excited to go to work every
day as I am just you know go do
something on a Saturday night and so the
idea
finding your passion is ironically
simple because you should be doing stuff
that you enjoy sometimes what is the
stuff that you enjoy and then what is
the stuff that you love who the people
you love and what are that's what they
all have in common how do you explain
when things don't go as we assumed or
better how do you explain when others
are able to achieve things that seem to
defy all of the assumptions for example
why is Apple so innovative year after
year after year after year they're more
innovative than all their competition
and yet they're just a computer company
they're just like everyone else they
have the same access to the same talent
the same agencies the same consultant
the same media then why is it that they
seemed to have something different why
is it that Martin Luther King led the
civil rights movement he wasn't the only
man who suffered in a pre-civil Rights
America and he certainly wasn't the only
great orator of the day why him and why
is it that the Wright brothers were able
to figure out control powered man flight
when there were certainly other teams
who were better qualified better funded
and they didn't achieve powered man
flight the Wright brothers beat them to
it there's something else at play here
about three and a half years ago I made
a discovery and this discovery
profoundly changed my view on how I
thought the world worked and it even
profoundly changed the way in which I
operate in it as it turns out there's a
pattern as it turns out all the great
and inspiring leaders and organizations
in the world whether it's Apple or
Martin Luther King or the Wright
brothers they all think act and
communicate the exact same way and it's
the complete opposite to everyone else
all I did was codified and it's probably
the world's simplest idea I call it the
Golden Circle
why how what this little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire where others aren't
let me define the terms really quickly
every single person every single
organization on the planet knows what
they do 100 percent some know how they
do it with you call it your
differentiating value proposition or
your proprietary process or your USP but
very very few people or organizations
know why they do what they do and by why
I don't need to make a profit that's a
result it's always a result by why I
mean what's your purpose what's your
cause what's your belief why does your
organization exist why do you get out of
bed in the morning and why should anyone
care well as a result the way we think
the way we act the way we communicate is
from the outside in and it's obvious we
go from the clearest thing to the
fuzziest thing but the inspired leaders
in the inspire or inspired organizations
regardless of their size regardless of
their industry all think act and
communicate from the inside out let me
give you an example I use Apple because
they're easy to understand and everybody
gets it if Apple were like everyone else
a marketing message from them might
sound like this we make great computers
they're beautifully designed simple to
use and user friendly want to buy one
and that's how most of us communicate
that's how most marketing is done that's
how most sales them and that's how most
of us communicate interpersonally we
save what we do we say how we're
different or how we better and we expect
some sort of behavior or purchase vote
something like that here's our new law
firm we have the best lawyers with the
biggest clients we have you know we
always perform for our clients do
business with us here's our new car it
gets great gas mileage it has you know
leather seats by our car but it's
uninspiring here's how Apple actually
communicates everything we do we believe
in challenging the status quo we believe
in thinking differently
the way we challenge in status quo is by
making our products beautifully designed
simple to use and user friendly we just
happen to make great computers wanna buy
one totally different right you're ready
to buy a computer from me all I did was
reverse the order of the information
what it proves to us is that people
don't buy what you do people buy why you
do it people don't buy what you do they
buy why you do it
this explains why every single person in
this room is perfectly comfortable
buying a computer from Apple but we're
also perfectly comfortable buying an mp3
player from Apple or a phone from Apple
or a DVR from Apple but as I said before
Apple's just a computer company there's
nothing that distinguishes them
structurally from any of their
competitors their competitors are all
equally qualified to make all of these
products in fact they tried a few years
ago gateway came out with flat-screen
TVs they're eminently qualified to make
flat-screen tvs they've been making some
flat-screen monitors for years Dell came
out with mp3 players and PDAs and they
make great quality products and they can
make perfectly well design products and
nobody bought one in fact talking about
it now we can't even imagine buying an
mp3 player from Dell why would you buy
an mp3 player from a computer company
but we do it every day people don't buy
what you do they buy why you do it
the goal is not to do business with
anybody with everybody who needs what
you have the goal is to do business with
people who believe what you believe
here's the best part none of what I'm
telling you is my opinion it's all
grounded in the tenets of biology not
psychology biology if you look at a
cross-section of the human brain looking
from the top down what you see is the
human brain is actually broken into
three major components that
karley perfectly with the golden circle
our newest brain our Homo Sapien brain
our neocortex corresponds with the what
level the neocortex is responsible for
all of our rational and analytical
thought and language the middle two
sections make up our limbic brains and
our limbic brains are responsible for
all of our feelings like trust and
loyalty it's also responsible for all
human behavior
all decision-making and it has no
capacity for language in other words
when we communicate from the outside in
yes people can understand vast amounts
of complicated information like features
and benefits and facts and figures just
doesn't drive behavior when we
communicate from the inside out we're
talking directly to the part of the
brain that controls behavior and then we
allow people to rationalize it with the
tangible things we say and do this is
where gut decisions come from you know
sometimes you can give somebody all the
facts and your figures in these I know
what all the facts in detail say but it
just doesn't feel right why would we use
that verb it doesn't feel right because
the part of the brain that controls
decision-making doesn't control language
and the best we can muster up is I don't
know it just doesn't feel right or
sometimes you say you're leading with
your heart through you're leading with
your soul oh I hate to break it to you
those on the other body parts
controlling your behavior it's all
happening here in your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making and not language but if
you don't know why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do then how will anybody how will
you ever get people to vote for your by
something from you or more importantly
be loyal and want to be a part of what
it is what that you do again the goal is
not just as to sell people who need what
you have the goal is to sell people who
believe what you believe the goal is not
just to hire people who need a job it's
to hire people who believe what you
believe I always say that you know this
if you if you if you um hire people just
because they can do a job they'll work
for your money but if you hire people
who believe what you believe they work
for you with blood and sweat and tears
and no era nowhere else is there a
better example of this than with the
Wright brothers most people don't know
about Samuel Pierpont Langley and back
in the early 20th century the pursuit of
powered man flight was like the dot-com
of the day everybody was trying it and
Samuel Pierpont Langley had what we
assume to be the recipe for success I
mean even now when you ask people why
did your product or why did your company
fail and people always give you the
permeate same permutation of the same
three things undercapitalized the wrong
people bad market conditions it was the
same
three things so let's explore that
Samuel Pierpont Langley was given
$50,000 by the War Department to figure
out this flying machine money was no
problem
he held a seat at Harvard and worked at
the Smithsonian and was extremely
well-connected he knew all the big minds
of the day he hired the best minds money
could find and the market conditions
were fantastic
the New York Times followed him around
everywhere and everyone was rooting for
Langley and how come we've never heard
of Samuel Pierpont Langley a few hundred
miles away in Dayton Ohio Orville and
Wilbur Wright they had none of what we
consider to be the recipe for success
they had no money they paid for their
dream with the proceeds from their
bicycle shop not a single person on the
Wright brothers team had a college
education
not even Orville or Wilbur and the New
York Times followed them around nowhere
the difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a caused by a purpose by
a belief they believed that if they
could figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he want to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches and lo
and behold look what happened the people
who believed in the Wright brothers
dream worked with them with blood and
sweat and tears the others just worked
for the paycheck and they tell stories
of how every time the Wright brothers
went out they would have to take five
sets of parts because that's how many
times they would crash before they came
in for supper and eventually on December
17th 1903 the Wright brothers took
flight and no one was there to even
experience it we found out about it a
few days later and further proof that
Langley was motivated by the wrong thing
the day the Wright brothers took flight
he quit
he could have said that's an amazing
discovery guys and I will improve upon
your technology but he didn't he wasn't
first he didn't get rich he didn't get
famous so quick people don't buy what
you do they buy why you do it and if you
talk about what you believe you will
attract those who believe what you
believe but why is it important to
attract those who believe what you
believe something called the law of
diffusion of innovation and if you don't
know the law you definitely know the
terminology the first two and a half
percent of our population are our
innovators the next thirteen and a half
percent of our population are our early
adopters the next 34% are your early
majority your late majority and your
laggards the only reason these people by
touch-tone phones is because you can't
buy rotary phones anymore
[Music]
we all sit at various places at various
times on the scale but the law of
diffusion of innovation tells us is that
if you want mass-market success or
mass-market acceptance of an idea you
cannot have it until you achieve this
tipping point between 15 and 18 percent
market penetration and then the system
tips and I love asking businesses what's
your conversion on new business and
they'd love to sell you oh it's about
10% proudly well you can trip over 10%
of the customers we all have about 10%
who just get it that's how we describe
them right that's like that gut feeling
oh they just get it the problem is how
do you find the ones that just get it
before you're doing business with them
versus the ones who don't get it
so it's this here this little gap that
you have to close is Geoffrey more close
o'clock crossing the chasm because you
see the early majority will not try
something until someone else has tried
it first and these guys the innovators
in the early adopters they're
comfortable making those gut decisions
they're more comfortable making those
intuitive decisions that are driven by
what they believe about the world
and not just what product is available
these are the people who stood on line
for six hours to buy an iPhone when they
first came out when you could have just
walked into the store the next week and
bought one off the shelf these are the
people who spent $40,000 on flat-screen
TVs when they first came out even though
the technology was substandard and by
the way they didn't do it because the
technology was so great they did it for
themselves it's because they wanted to
be first people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it and what you do
simply proves what you believe in fact
people will do the things that prove
what they believe the reason that person
bought the iPhone on the first in the
first six hours of stood and Sigma in
line for six hours was because of what
they believed about the world and how
they wanted everybody to see them they
were first people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it so let me give
you a famous example a famous failure
and a famous success of the law of
diffusion of innovation first the famous
failure it's a commercial example as we
said before a second ago the recipe for
success is money in the right people in
the right marketing conditions right you
should have success then look at TiVo
from the time TiVo came out about eight
or nine years ago to this current day
they are the single highest quality
product on the market hands down there
is no dispute they were extremely
well-funded market conditions were
fantastic I mean we use TiVo as a verb
like TiVo stuff on my piece of junk Time
Warner DVR all the time
but t-bones commercial failure they've
never made money and when they went IPO
their stock was at about 30 or 40
dollars then plummeted and it's never
traded above 10 in fact I don't thinks
it's even traded above 6 except for a
couple of little spikes because you see
when Tebow launched their product they
told us all what they had they said we
have a product that pauses live TV skips
commercials rewinds live TV and
memorizes your viewing habits without
you even asking and the cynical majority
said you don't believe you we don't need
it we don't like it you're scaring us
what if they had said if you're the kind
of person who likes to have total
control over every aspect of your life
boy do we have a product for you
it causes live TV skips commercials
memorizes your viewing habits etc etc
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
serves as the proof of what you believe
now let me give you a successful example
of the law of diffusion of innovation in
the summer of 1963 250,000 people showed
up on the mall in Washington to hear dr.
King speak they sent out no invitations
and there was no website to check the
date how do you do that well dr. King
wasn't the only man in America
who was the who's a great orator he
wasn't the only man in America who
suffered in a pre-civil Rights America
in fact some of his ideas were bad but
he had a gift he didn't go around
telling people what needed to change in
America you know he went around and told
people what he believed I believe
I believe he told people and people who
believed what he believed took his cause
and they made it their own and they told
me and some of those people created
structures to get the word out even more
and lo and behold 250,000 people showed
up on the right day on the right time to
hear him speak how many of them showed
up for him zero
they should even since it's what they
believed about America that got them to
travel on a bus for eight hours to stand
in the Sun in Washington for in the
middle of August it's what they believed
and it wasn't about black versus white
25 percent of the audience was white dr.
King believed that there are two types
of laws in this world those that are
made by a higher lottery authority and
those that are made by man and nothing
till all the laws that are made by man
are consistent with the laws that are
made by the higher thought he will we
live in a just world it just so happens
that the civil rights movement was the
perfect thing to help him bring his
cause to life we followed him not for
him but for ourselves and by the way he
gave the I have a dream speech not the I
have a planned speech
[Music]
listen to politicians now with the
comprehensive 12-point plans are not
inspiring anybody because there were
leaders and there are those who read
leaders hold a position of power or
authority but those who lead inspire us
with other individuals or organizations
we follow those who lead but because we
have to but because we want to we follow
those who lead not for them but for
ourselves and it's those who start with
why that have the ability to inspire
those around them
we'll find others who inspire them thank
you very much thank you guys so much for
watching I made this video because Lex
vent the Herrick asked me to so there's
a famous entrepreneur that you would
like me to profile next please leave it
down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I also love to know which
clip resonated the most with you today
what did Simon say that had the biggest
impact what change you're gonna make to
your life your business after watching
this video please leave it down the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
[Music]
raise your standard cool it's not one
drop of my self-worth depends on your
acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten Rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual Clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details
you